so um when it comes to christmas now i
mean there's two images i suppose being
painted off your good self um we see uh
the guardian lean mean extreme uh
they're they're calling you um today and
the sun seem very very happy there the
headline is ho ho homes so
do you see yourself as santa claus or
the grinch
as neither uh i see myself as i see
myself as a chancellor every day of the
year not just christmas it's got to go
on making difficult decisions to keep
our economy on course keep it growing
make sure that people can enjoy good
christmases but also have jobs in the
new year
and that's what we're seeing here in
peru i want to see that
across the whole of the country
people though
don't feel that much better off i know
it's very very difficult i started this
by saying the task obviously hurt julian
why don't people feel that they're
actually better off and what should
people be feeling what what what do you
want to prepare everybody wants you know
more money they want to feel job
security is going to happen for them
what should they be feeling what is the
reality
well i think people do feel the return
of economic security in our country i
think people feel more secure in their
employment and of course there are many
hundreds of thousands of people
in the last few years who were
unemployed who've now got jobs
of course in the end
a country can only be as rich as its
economy and you've got to grow that
economy and when you have a big economic
crash as we did four or five years ago
under the labour government that has an
impact on people's living standards
that's what happens when economic policy
fails i know economic security returns
and living standards rise as the economy
grows yeah